action directe en justice les quatre
chefs terroristes devant la cour il
répondre de l'assassinât de georges
besse le patron de la régie renault
la catastrophe aérienne de leicester 46
morts elle aurait pu être beaucoup plus
meurtrière mais là aussi failli être
évité rika zaraï inculpé mais pas pour
ses livres elle est accusée d' exercice
illégal de la pharmacie dans la
préparation et s'est produit ici à
droite à lyon michel noir s'attaque au
maire francisque collomb il lance sa
propre liste soutenue par le rpr
charles pasqua à l'heure de vérité
new look il répondra à des questions
d'actualité sur les otages ou sur les
unit bonsoir
la boîte noire du boeing britannique a
été retrouvée tout à l'heure le 737 de
la compagnie midland airways s'est
écrasé hier soir dans le comté de
leicester dernier bilan 46 morts 80
blessés une catastrophe qui s'est joué à
quelques secondes elle aurait pu être
évité mais sans le sang froid des
pilotes
elle aurait pu encore être beaucoup plus
meurtrière enquête en angleterre bruno
gex
c'est encore plus terrible que je ne le
pensais
margaret thatcher s'est déclarée
bouleversée lorsqu'elle s'est rendue sur
les lieux de la catastrophe
à ses côtés paul chan hom la ministre
des transports britannique et le
directeur des midlands airways
michael bishop le premier ministre a
tenu à féliciter l'équipe de sauveteurs
qui s'est montré particulièrement
efficace et rapide pour peu après
l'accident
un accident qui restera dans la mémoire
des habitants de la petite ville
le key words and trying times
l'avion volait très bas j'ai vu un des
moteurs prendre chose il le peut il est
arrivé au dessus de la colline la rasant
sous les arbres qui bordent l'autoroute
autre témoignage celui dans des rescapés
du boeing il a entendu le pilote annoncé
aux passagers que l'avion allait
s'écraser
il y avait d'un côté de moi une femme
complètement paniqué je les baisser la
tête de force pour la protéger moi j'ai
pas eu le temps je me suis retrouvé avec
une grosse bosse défaillance technique
dans les réacteurs c'est la thèse que
retient province dans les enquêteurs la
lecture des boîtes noires est le
témoignage des deux pilotes encore en
vie permettront sans doute d'ici les
prochains jours de faire la lumière sur
les causes de l'accident
un procès fossé d'avant celui d'action
directe les quatre chefs de
l'organisation terroriste ont en effet
décidé de se taire depuis l'instruction
ils ne répondent pas aux questions
aujourd'hui il comparaissait devant une
cour spéciale composée de magistrats une
cour spéciale pour juger des actions
terroristes
ils sont accusés du meurtre de l'ancien
patron de la régie renault georges besse
a battu en novembre 86 le procès a
commencé dans un climat tendu et avec un
dispositif de sécurité exceptionnel au
palais de justice
dominique verdeilhan deux en deux ans
que madame georges besse attendait ce
face à face aux six jours avec les
quatre présumés coupables du meurtre de
son époux pour ce nouveau procès ou le
noyau dur d'action directe doit pour la
première fois à répondre d'un assassinat
un important dispositif de forces de
police et une fouille systématique du
public ont été mises en place pour toute
la semaine aux côtés de madame baisse
ses enfants et l'actuel pdg de la régie
renault raymond lévy qui s'est lui aussi
constitué partie civile
une partie civile qui par la bouche de m
sarda considère ce procès comme celui
d'un assassinat l'assassinât d'un père
de famille et d'un chef d'entreprise
si la partie civile a fait appeler à la
barre deux ministre edith cresson et
andré giraud c'est simplement pour
rendre hommage à la personnalité de
georges besse celui que ménigon cipriani
aux gros et rouillan appelle la brute
baisse pour les quatre accusés ce procès
je cite le moement pour dresser un bilan
économique d'un sacrifice humain
collectif le licenciement d'ouvriers de
la régie renault
si la partie civile a fait appel à deux
ministres la défense voulait donner une
dimension politique à 60 ans voulant
faire entendre à la barre le ministre
actuel de l'industrie roger fouroux le
biologiste albert jacquard et le
syndicaliste henri krasucki une demande
rejetée par le président versini tout au
long de cette jeu
on est madame baisse est resté le visage
fermé dévisageant parfois les deux
femmes
plusieurs fois ce soir les membres
d'action directe ont menacé de quitter
la salle d'audience afin d'aller
préparer leur défense
en coulisses ils ont demandé également
plusieurs fois à être incarcéré tout le
long de ce procès par la même maison
d'arrêt à quoi bon a dit la partie
civile puisque depuis deux ans il
déclare n'avoir rien à dire et qu'ils
ont toujours refusé
oui j'ajoute que le jour même de
l'ouverture du procès helyette bess
second rôle mais sympathisante d'action
directe a été interpellé à paris cette
femme de 57 ans qui n'a aucun rapport
avec le pdg de la régie renault malgré
son homonymie helyette bess donc avaient
été remises en liberté samedi dernier
mais interdite de séjour à paris elle
est restée dans la capitale et à la donc
été arrêté la sphère rika zaraï depuis
que la chanteuse a sorti son deuxième
livre mais secret naturel la polémique
n'a pas cessé d'abord il ya eu les
médecins maintenant ce sont les
pharmaciens résultats rika zaraï a été
inculpé pour complicité d'exercice
illégal de la pharmacie
alors disons tout de suite que ce n'est
pas pour son livre mais pour les
produits qu'elle fabrique et qu'elle
vend dans la région d'angers
l'enquète dana blues voilà lusine de
rika zaraï elle se trouve à saint
sylvain d'anjou près d'angers
c'est ici que les plantes à l'éffigie de
la chanteuse sont préparés avant d'être
vendus en grande surface
le plus souvent à côté de sa médecine
naturelle près de trois millions
d'exemplaires et de ses secrets naturel
qui ne se contente pas de livrer des
recettes de grand-mère ses recettes
prétendent aussi soigner les maladies
les plus graves
ce qui vaut aujourd'hui à rika zaraï une
inculpation pour exercice illégal de la
pharmacie
je suis une femme innocente respectueuse
de loi je suis une femme qui écrit des
livres et ça fait 15 ans que je lutte
pour améliorer la santé des français
mais est ce que les gens savent que
quand on dit qu'elle est qu'ils veulent
c'est bon pour le sommeil quand le monde
c'est bon pour la digestion c'est
exercice illégal de la pharmacie
eh bien je vais contre attaqué en disant
que je ne vends que des plantes libéré
par les ministères de la santé que je
suis une femme qui écrit des livres
comme d'autres centaines des milliers de
personnes en france et que je ne vois
pas à moins d'être un pays des
dictatures commence l'éthique on
m'attaque uniquement moi pour l'ordre
des pharmaciens qui a déposé sa plainte
il y a deux ans il fallait absolument
prévenir le public de la menace rika
zaraï rika zaraï à qui il demande
aujourd'hui d'appliquer la loi
l'application de la loi eh bien ça
serait qu elle demande que son
laboratoire devienne un laboratoire
pharmaceutique c'est ce qui serait le
mieux pour elle que de conduire
continuer un combat complètement
inutiles en jouant les martyrs que les
pharmaciens lui en veulent de formation
lui en veulent pas maintenant la justice
va devoir trancher
rika zaraï at elle oui ou non outrepassé
ses droits et surtout ses compétences
rika zaraï propose de soigner aux
plantes souvent bien inoffensive alors
on se demande pourquoi ce courroux de la
faculté de la justice c'est qu'il existe
dans ce domaine de l'herboristerie mais
aussi dans le domaine des médecines
douces ou parallèle tout une législation
que chacun doit respecter
et puis c'est aussi vous allez devoir un
commerce très florissant explications
jean daniel flaysakier 400 g de plantes
par an c'est ce que chacun d'entre nous
consomme sous forme d'infusion de
décoction ou de gélules les 22000
pharmaciens français et les rares
herboriste diplômés ont vendu l'an
dernier 15 millions de boîtes de sachets
ou de gélules à base de simples médecine
mais ils ne sont pas les seuls à
commercialiser ses produits
il ya en effet 34 plan dit libéré c'est
à dire des plantes qui peuvent être
vendus par n'importe qui et seulement 7
de ces plantes peuvent être mélangés le
tilleul lamente la camomille la verveine
l'orangé hibiscus ou le cynorrhodon
aucun autre mélange ne ferait pas plus
qu'il n'est permis d'introduire des
notices de prescription dans les boîtes
de ses produits
toutes les autres plantes sont
considérés comme des médicaments et doit
faire l'objet d'une autorisation de mise
sur le marché
d'ailleurs un prochain décret dressera
une liste de 115 plan dont la germandrée
le thé vert ou la passiflore que seuls
les pharmaciens pourront désormais
vendre la politique de fourvière à la
croix-rousse on ne parle que de ça ce
soir
la droite est divisée à lyon lyon c'est
l'une des villes et non des moindres où
l'udf et le rpr ne sont pas parvenus à
se mettre d'accord c'est à dire à une
liste commune
ce soir la division est consommée
puisque michel noir député rpr du rhône
13 ans tracé sur une liste contre le
maire francisque collomb soutenu lui par
raymond barre lyon claude régent
on prend les mêmes et on recommence
comme en 83 il y aura des primaires au
sein de la droite lyonnaise le rpr
atypique michel noir se présentait
contre le maire sortant edf francisque
collomb
pourquoi suis-je convient parce que j'ai
une passion servirions et servir là mon
pays j'ai une volonté constituer une
équipe compétente
loin des jeux politiciens j'ai enfin une
ambition apporter réponse aux
difficultés que les habitants de notre
site et vivent quotidiennement depuis
dix années
je suis député de lyon et je sers notre
ville et ses habitants avec ardeur avec
l'ancien premier ministre monsieur
raymond barre je suis le seul élu de
lyon dont l'expérience gouvernementale a
aidé et de rallions une référence
habile raymond barre ne semble pas en
tout cas choqué par la candidature de
michel noir même si l'ancien premier
ministre sera très probablement aux
côtés du maire sortant
la décision de monsieur noir ne me
choque pas je suis vous le savez
partisans du pluralisme dans
l'opposition comme dans la majorité faut
penser que vous pouvez battre une
nouvelle fois monsieur noir mais j'en
suis certain il pose problème c'est la
répétition 1983 nous reprenons nous
amusé pendant des mois et des mois est
pas prêt on vient dire que c'est moi qui
suis un lâcheur pas du tout monsieur
noir a dit que lyon s'essoufflait
s'essoufflait et lui ce souffle opa nom
de francisque collomb jours à la
stabilité la sécurité michel noir le
renouvellement
l'ancien ministre de jacques chirac a
enregistré dès ce soir le soutien sans
réserve du rdr nationale l'événement
politique c'est ce soir sur antenne 2
l'heure de vérité d'abord une nouvelle
formule qui renouvellera un petit peu le
genre de cette émission animée par
françois henri de virieu ensuite
l'invité de ce soir est en plein dans
l'actualité c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire car c'est charles pasqua
on parle beaucoup de lui ou plutôt de sa
loi sur l'immigration mais charles
pasqua puisque vous êtes avec nous pour
un court instant avant l'heure de vérité
on a beaucoup parlé de vous récemment
aussi à propos d'elly
les rations des otages par exemple les
deux petites fillettes valente alors
est-ce que ce soir dans l'heure de
vérité puisque jusqu'à présent vous êtes
tu es ce que vous allez apporter des
révélations sur cette affaire écoutez je
répondrai aux questions qui lui seront
posées mais je verrai ça tout à l'heure
où mais je vous êtes décidé à répondre à
pierre joxe par exemple je dirais je
répondre aux questions que l'on me
posera monsieur york ce n'est pas sur le
plateau
mais s'il veut dialoguer avec moi par
minitel pourquoi pas mais vous êtes prêt
à dire ce que vous avez fait réellement
au moment de la libération de ces droits
que je vous ai répondu c'est tout bien
d'écouter on vous retrouvera tout à
l'heure de toute façon j'imagine aussi
que vous allez beaucoup parlé de
l'immigration écoutez par exemple ce
qu'a dit françois mitterrand qui est
revenu à la charge sur ce sujet plus que
jamais monsieur mitterrand souhaite
assouplir cette fameuse loi pasqua il
l'a encore dit cet après midi à la
sorbonne au cours des assises
internationales sur les nouvelles
solidarités
écoutez je vais lire j'ai été très
surpris mais vraiment surpris oui pas
grand chose qui ne surprennent
aujourd'hui mais très surpris de voir
que ce que j'avais dit le 31 200 1988
pouvait provoquer un tel trouble dans
certains milieux
un trou blog roman est même heure en
rien de scandaleux sans doute avait
l'oeil et qu'ils agiraient m'ont fixé
sur l'horizon des élections municipales
fête pouvait s'expliquer comme ça si
j'avais eu du souci au même titre que
ceux qui m'en faisait le reproche je
devrais plutôt pas dit ce que j'aurai
dire parce que parce que à voir les
statistiques actuelles c'est pas
forcément le meilleur argument électoral
dans un quartier de marseille dans
certains quartiers open par ici voilà je
reviens un court instant municipal nous
reparlerons des assises internationales
sur la seule sur les nouvelles
solidarités dans un instant je reviens
un court instant municipal avec ces deux
informations dont je viens de prendre
connaissance
d'abord lyon toujours francisque collomb
le maire vient de déclarer raymond barre
sera sur ma liste
et puis michel rocard le premier
ministre qui a annoncé sa candidature
pour les municipales donc à la mairie de
conflans sainte honorine
voilà les assises internationales sur
les nouvelles solidarités donc se sont
ouvertes ce matin il s'agit de voir ce
qu'on peut faire dans ce domaine mais
sur toutes les solidarités il n'y a pas
que le problème des immigrés ni celui du
chômage ni celui du manque d'argent il
ya aussi par exemple la solidarité
envers les drogués pourquoi pas bien
souvent eux aussi victimes
exemple de cette solidarité ce qui aide
les drogués à se réinsérer dans la vie
sociale
après s'être soigné christophe martet
jean-françois bernigaud reportage
patiemment minutieusement olivier bigeon
restaure des meubles est ébéniste d'art
installé à son compte depuis deux ans il
gagne bien sa vie
une situation impensable il ya quelques
années quand olivier n'avait pour seule
obsession que la drogue une dépendance
totale qui a duré trois ans
trois années qu'olivier veut maintenant
oubliée car il s'est battu pour en
sortir
psychologiquement c'est difficile de se
réintégrer vraiment dans un système
comme dans le monde du travail mais je
crois qu'il faut avoir un petit peu
volonté et beaucoup de passion pour ce
qu'on fait je crois c'est vraiment
l'essentiel dans la vie c'est d'avoir un
métier qui vous prend qui me passionne à
ce moment là je crois qu'il est capable
de tout faire
c'est ici à l'association oiseaux bleus
qu'olivier a appris son métier
cinquante jeunes sont accueillis chaque
année tous d'anciens drogue et à
l'héroïne ou à d'autres drogues dures
tous arrivent après des cures
successives de désintoxication certains
après des séjours en prison tous
marginalisé par des années de galère il
rentre ici sans drogue et volontaires
pour beaucoup c'est la dernière planche
de salut
la vie que je menais alex turner non je
pense qu'il fallait que je fasse ce
choix je les fais ça que je suis là et
concrètement votre vie a vraiment changé
depuis vous avez découvert ce métier si
la sortie ferme du monde la toxicomanie
oublier non plus j'ai réappris à queue
avec le goût la valeur de l'argent la
valeur du temps
le support est à contout ici le centre
est subventionnée en partie par la
sécurité sociale et par des dons privés
les jeunes encadrés par quatre
éducateurs deviennent des artisans à
part entière les meubles sont donnés à
l'association ou achetés dans des
brocantes restaurer puis revendus lors
de journées portes ouvertes
une grande partie de leur salaire et
messieurs raconte bloqué ce sera un
capital de départ à la sortie du centre
après deux ans de formation actuellement
nous avons en projet d'autres formations
toujours artistique et débouchant sur un
gagne pain par exemple la ferronnerie
d'art ou actuellement il y a sûrement
des débouchés et aussi la faïencerie
d'art
toujours grâce au mode art qui revient
car beaucoup des jeunes qui viennent
chez nous veulent une formation
valorisante qui pourra vraiment donner
un sens à leur vie
bien sûr certains craquent replonge
mais depuis dix ans que l'association
existe près d'une centaine de jeunes
s'en sont définitivement sorti à propos
de solidarité toujours ce chiffre donné
aujourd'hui par le ministre des affaires
sociales claude evin cent mille
personnes ont déjà présenté un dossier
pour bénéficier du rmi le revenu minimal
d'insertion ce rmi comble on le voit un
besoin qui était très vaste économie
avec les bons résultats de la régie
renault avec un nouveau record de
véhicules vendu un million huit cent
cinquante mille renault est ainsi le
quatrième constructeur européen est le
premier français au même moment la
chambre syndicale des constructeurs auto
publié ses résultats
c'est très bon aussi pour l'ensemble des
constructeurs français en fait une année
record en 88 la conférence sur les armes
chimiques
c'est à paris c'est à paris où sont
réunis vous savez vous le savez 141 pays
en cinq jours ces pays cherchent à
trouver un consensus mais cela paraît
bien difficile thème général de la
discorde
les petits pays c'est à dire souvent les
pays pauvres 10 aux autres pourquoi
renoncer à nos armes chimiques puisque
vous pays riches vous avez vos armes
nucléaires qui sont beaucoup plus
dangereuses georges bortoli
on attendait le délégué de la libye pays
qui en matière d'armes chimiques fait
figure d'accusée potentiel malgré ces
accusations rituel contre israël et les
états unis il s'est montré plutôt plus
modéré que de coutume c'est la bonne
surprise de cette journée marque et
d'autre part par un nouveau réquisitoire
de l'iran contre l'irak
la condamnation de l'irak et des
sanctions contre ce pays qui a utilisé
des armes chimiques depuis sept ans est
un élément très important pour le futur
car sinon les autres pays pourraient
être tentés de suivre le même chemin
clinique toute forme le destiny tchèque
en chine dans cette enceinte de l'unesco
109 délégués représentant 9 pays des
grands et des moins grands comme les
comores où les îles cook se sont fait
inscrire pour prendre la parole d'ici
mercredi
mais l'attention maintenant se porte moi
vers les discours que vers le texte
final de la conférence qui est en train
de se rédiger dans les coulisses
ce texte sera difficile à mettre au
point parce que les pays arabes voudrait
que il fasse référence explicitement aux
périls de l'armé nucléaire
en plus du péril chimiques alors est ce
que ça pourrait faire capoter la
conférence d'ici mercredi non c'est peu
probable le vent est à la modération et
tout porte à croire que cette conférence
condamnera comme elle doit le faire de
la façon la plus ferme et la plus
générale le péril des armes chimiques
we r vous le savez l'union soviétique
avait proposé de réduire et de détruire
même son stock d'armes chimiques en fait
c'est un geste qui lui coûte pas
beaucoup car à l'union soviétique
détruira surtout les armes anciennes
comme d'ailleurs le font les états unis
qui depuis des années détruisent eux
aussi leurs armes chimiques anciennes
pour les remplacer par des armes moins
toxique pour la première fois une équipe
de télévision s'est rendu dans une de
ses usines d'armes chimiques américaines
dans les montagnes rocheuses au centre
du pays dans l'utah elle a aussi chez à
cette équipe d'antenne 2 assister à
l'entraînement de jeunes recrues
féminines voici le reportage donc de
cette équipe paul nahon
francis friedland
dans ce camp de l'armée américaine en
caroline du sud on apprend très vite à
ses jeunes recrues à se protéger des gaz
en cas d' attaques de l'ennemi
depuis toujours larmes chimique a
constitué la terreur des populations
civiles et des militaires mais ces
masques sont une protection dérisoire
face à la puissance de destruction des
armes chimiques moderne
les américains ont commencé la
fabrication de ces armes
pendant les deux guerres mondiales il
possède des stocks énormes mais c'est en
1960 que les états unis décident de
détruire une partie de leurs stocks
sous la pression du congrès et de leurs
opinions publiques nous avons pu
pénétrer dans l'un des camps de l'armée
dans l'ouest du pays perdu dans le
désert de l'utah
cette usine militaire qui est en train
de détruire 42% des stocks d'armes
chimiques une usine entièrement
automatisée mais il nous a été
impossible de savoir combien de tonnes
de produits chimiques
ils étaient stockés secret défense
nous aurons terminé tout ce travail en
1997 à cette date
lusine sera détruite et décontaminer et
l'environnement sera à nouveau propre
voulez vous dire qu'en 1997 tous les
stocks seront détruits absolument
dans ces obus en cours de
décontamination de l'ypérite ou gaz
moutarde l'un des plus toxiques des
agents suffocant qui bloque l'influx
nerveux ou encore des neurotoxiques des
gaz et mot toxique qui provoque la mort
par arrêt respiratoire
ces agents pouvaient être utilisés grâce
à des munitions traditionnel des bombes
ou des missiles aujourd'hui toutes ces
armes sont dépassés d'où leur
destruction sans oublier que leur
stockage étaient extrêmement dangereux
pour l'environnement
depuis deux ans les états unis fabrique
un nouveau système d'armes chimiques
appelée système binaire
c'est à dire que dans une usine à on va
fabriquer un produit chimique non
toxiques dans une autre usine b on va
produire un autre produit chimique non
toxique aussi et c'est le mélange la
réunion si vous voulez de ces deux
produits qui va former la nouvelle arme
chimique mortel en cas convient donc
sous une forme ou sous une autre
aucune des grandes puissances n'a
renoncé alarme chimique certains pays
testent même dans le plus grand secret
des armes bactériologiques ce que
winston churchill appelait déjà les
poisons du diable les moudjahidines
afghans ne veulent plus négocier avec
l'union soviétique ils ont rompu les
pourparlers ils attendent le retrait de
l'armée rouge le 15 février c'est ce
qu'a déclaré à islamabad au pakistan le
chef de la résistance afghane
voyons maintenant d'autres informations
de l'actualité internationale
en bref en images michel mon compte et
après six mois d'enquêté le procureur
général du pirée reconnaît enfin
l'innocence de laurent vigneron
le jeune français de 22 ans tué le 11
juillet dernier lors de l'attentât sur
le site you for hausse avait été
longtemps présenté comme un terroriste
par les autorités grecques
toutes les charges retenues contre lui
sont désormais abandonnées
en revanche les poursuites ont été
engagées contre un libanais mohammed
josanne du groupe abu nidal identifié
lui comme le véritable assassin
ces deux derniers jours au moins 49
morts dans les violents combats qui se
poursuivent au sud-liban des milices
chiites d'amal trop syrienne et du
hezbollah pro iranienne s'affrontent
dans les villages entourant la ville de
saïda des combats décrits comme
d'horribles massacres par la police
libanaise
amal et le hezbollah se rejettent
mutuellement la responsabilité de ces
violences entre tentant de s'interposer
et miliciens du fatah palestinien au
liban toujours un terrible anniversaire
les 1000 jours de détention de john
mccarthy
ce journaliste anglais enlevé à beyrouth
le 17 avril 1986 fait partie des treize
occidentaux encore détenus au liban
il aura attendu 55 ans pour devenir à
son tour le 125e dieu du ciel empereur
du japon éternelle en quatre minutes
d'une cérémonie très solennelle
l'empereur akihito s'est engagé à ne
faire qu'un avec son peuple
quoi qu'il arrive devant 258 députés
le fils de l'empereur hirohito a
également souhaité la paix pour le monde
et la prospérité pour son pays un espoir
pour la petite or la sphère était jugé
en appel aujourd'hui à poitiers alors je
vous le rappelle cette affaire aura
quatre ans maintenant à l'âge de 6 mois
elle a été abandonnée par sa mère est
recueilli par une famille d'accueil qui
l'adorent et qu'il élève pendant trois
ans mais l'été dernier coup de théâtre
la justice décide de rendre aurore à son
père qui jusque là s'étaient peut
manifester car il était en fait en
prison depuis la famille d'accueil et le
père se disputent l'enfant le père
refuse même aux autres leur droit de
visite
une douloureuse affaire donc qui va on
l'espère trouver un dénouement
anne 15 du rejet était à la cour d'appel
de poitiers trois heures de débats à
huis clos dans cette chambre des mineurs
de la cour d'appel de poitiers après
midi fait de malaise de coups de théâtre
le premier en forme de symbole il est
13h15 la mère naturelle d'aurore jusqu'à
hier introuvable jamais entendu par la
justice
arrive la première au palais elle a
décidé de témoigner de soutenir la
requête de garde de la famille d'accueil
face à eux l'avocate du père seul
deuxième surprise
il est 17 heures philippe v10 arrive en
catastrophe en taxi à la cour personne
ne sait qui l'a convoquée en urgence un
homme traqué qui dit qu aurore doit
rester chez lui qui se dit aussi
maintenant prêt à négocier
19 heures l'audience est close le
jugement mis en délibéré la décision
sera rendue par la cour l'estiment
rutile les débats ont été très complet
simple est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
pourquoi monsieur v10 est arrivé en
milieu d'après-midi à je n'ai pas je
n'ai pas de raison à donner
cette question il est arrivé était
présent devant la cour site où j'ai été
très heureuse que philips eddie ait pu
être reconduit nous avons amorcé un
dialogue
la cour nous a entendus et je crois que
j'ai aussi au nom de la famille hébrard
exprimer le don qu'ils avaient fait à
aurore des trois années de sa vie au
cours de laquelle elle s'est structurée
construite et que si jamais il fallait
donner ça or henri le donnerai vous qui
avez demandé est ce que monsieur v 10
soit entendu je la fais ce ex espérer la
cour le demander je crois que m gary
montméat compris effectivement qu'il
fallait que philips et d'hygiène
atmosphère qui peu à peu se détend
aurore savait que de porter d'autres on
se battait pour elle mais ce soir la
bataille a peut-être pris quelques
nuances c'est vrai qu'il y avait un
enjeu énorme et que ton l'avenir de
rentrer jouer aujourd'hui c'était de
grands moments d'émotion ça a été
mais je suis plein d'espoir tu plein
d'espoir jeu les magistrats ont opté
pour mesdames
pourquoi j'ai dit tout à l'heure je
crois que là était le procès du code
contre celui du coeur et ils ont un
coeur une enquête sociale a été ordonnée
dans la famille d'accueil chez le père
d'aurore une fille est absente dont on
ne cesse de parler
aurore dont la rumeur dit qu'elle
pourrait bien être enfin entendus par
les juges dans les prochains jours c'est
le monde à l'envers dans le domaine du
rugby
un français qui donne des conseils aux
anglais oui c'est pierre villepreux fait
rendu au portugal pour conseiller
l'équipe d'angleterre en stage reportage
de patrick montel hockey du pig au but
tout est prêt pour comme wissous et luis
niveau 8 opérateurs
la leçon de rugby de pierre villepreux
quand l'angleterre à quinze jours de
l'ouverture du tournoi bouleverse et
traditions et réapprend le ballon ovale
avec l'accent du sud ouest
le ralliement d'un french boy qui n'a
pourtant rien d'une trahison
il est impératif que tous les coachs du
monde
actuellement je dirais de manière un peu
malgré se donnent la main pour essayer
de faire progresser ce jeu il possède ce
qui manque le plus à une équipe anglaise
en pleine progression
la science du mouvement et la victoire
obtenue récemment devant l'australie n'a
pas encore fait oublier huit ans
d'approximations au niveau international
nous pensons que pierre peu par ses
idées novatrices nous apporter beaucoup
ce plan de la dynamique car en ce qui
concerne les phases statiques l'équipe
d'angleterre est déjà très au point
et puis pour le monde entier ville
procès la référence meilleurs arrières
du monde des années 70 reconversion
brillante depuis à la tête du stade
toulousain jusqu'aux bancs de
l'université où il enseigne sa
philosophie du rugby league alors pour
deux jours villepreux à exporter son
talent une démarche qui risque fort de
déplaire à la fédération française qui
elle jusqu'à présent c'est toujours
passer de ses services
et puis ces recettes miracle pourrait
bien faire basculer l'angleterre france
du 4 mars prochain la finale potentiel
du tout
voir 89 voilà je change de studio je
monte deux étages de l'avenue montaigne
à pied bien sûr pourront le retrouver
dans un autre studio celui de télématin
vous avez joué dans les escaliers oui
exact offre parce que j'ai prises
étaient les bons alors voilà je me
retrouve dans un studio de télé matin je
retrouve roger zabel et c'est pas un
hasard si je me retrouve ici c'est parce
que demain
télématin fait son quatrième
anniversaire et qu'à 34 ans ça
représente je crois j'ai calculé à peu
près mille quarante lever à 4 heures du
matin pour ceux qui étaient là dès le
début non plus sérieusement ça
représente effectivement des levés tôt
dès coucher tôt pour toute l'équipe de
télématin mais surtout je crois une très
grande joie vraiment une joueurs réels
de préparer chaque matin j'ai envie dire
le petit déjeuner pour les
téléspectateurs d'antenne 2 alors
comment vous fait les fans
alors on fait ça en recevant un invité
de marque qui est un fan de télé matin
c'est le louche
j'avais discuté un jour avec lui comme
sera cinéma et d'autres choses et il
m'avait dit sa passion pour télématin
donc on l'a invité à accepter très très
volontiers on va essayer de lui faire
prendre la caméra pour filmer à une
autre vedette de télé matin c'est victor
victor d'un petit bébé qui est né
exactement il ya quatre ans le 10
janvier 1985 lorsque william leymergie
présentait l'émission il sera là demain
matin on lui ferait un cadeau pour son
quatrième anniversaire
et puis nous aurons d'autres cadeaux des
télévisions étrangères du matin oui
parce que c'est vrai en fait dès les
télévisions étrangères le matin ça s'est
beaucoup beaucoup développée dans tous
les pays maintenant il ya une télé du
matin oui ça a commencé aux états unis
bien avant que la france est un journal
à 13 heures déjà ensuite il y avait
japon puis l'europe est venue quand même
beaucoup plus tard avec les anglais qui
ont démarré maintenant il ya l'allemagne
l'espagne le portugal l'italie enfin
tous les pays d'europe maintenant
pratiquement l'anglais mais la meilleure
c'est lé matin alors il y en a eu dans
télématin
demain rendez-vous 6h45 rangés comme
d'habitude 10h45 pour un réveil dans la
joie et dans la bonne humeur avec toute
l'équipe de télématin et un journal à
thunder 7h30 et 8h marque hautement et
catherine ceylac merci angers voit la
fin de cette édition du journal de 20
heures donc le
tout de suite la météo avec sophie
davant une habituée de télématin aussi
ensuite l'heure de vérité avec charles
pasqua vous l'avez vu l'édition d'un
françois henri de virieu et puis ensuite
l'informateur de la soirée ce sera henri
sannier avec notamment la dernière
édition du journal un tout petit peu
avant minuit excellente soirée sur
antenne 2 à demain soir
m